die chinesische weltraumbehörde hat die
kontrolle über ihr welt raumlabor
tiangong 1 verloren die raumstation
bewegt sich seitdem unkontrolliert auf
die erde zu jetzt gibt es aktuelle
berechnungen und vorhersagen zum
zeitpunkt des absturzes und es sieht
nicht gut aus zwar wird ein großteil von
ssangyong 1 schon sehr bald in der
atmosphäre verglühen
doch bis zu 100 kilogramm schwere
brocken könnten auf der erde einschlagen
wo und wann wie ist die lage jetzt in
klicks zum tanzen fiction herzlich
willkommen
es ist nicht das erste mal dass wir uns
um weltraumschrott gedanken machen
müssen weil er auf kollisionskurs mit
der erde ist vielleicht erinnert sich
der eine oder andere noch was hat 91
vielen bruchstücke des sowjetischen
raumstation silent 7 auf argentinien
herab menschen wurden zum glück nicht
verletzt weltraumexperten un experten
fordern immer wieder dass ausgediente
stationen und satelliten direkt im
weltraum recycelt werden anstatt sie
wieder mehr oder minder unkontrolliert
auf die erde stürzen zu lassen und ja
für django 1 gehen dass auf jeden fall
nicht im september 2011 hat china
tiangong-1 ins all geschickt übersetzt
heißt das übrigens also diese
chinesische nicht dauerhaft bemannte
raumstation so viel wie himmlischer
palast und tatsächlich ist eine art
palast für den weltraum zumindest 8,5
tonnen schwer
etwa so groß wie ein linienbus und
ausgestattet mit einem 14 kubikmeter
großen labor sowie einer kleinen wohn
ecke für die besucher von jcom1 in den
letzten sechs jahren hat das raumlabor
mehrere kopplungsmanöver mit
chinesischen raumschiffen der schein zu
reihe hinter sich gebracht doch schon im
letzten jahr war zwang 1 wohl außer
kontrolle geratenen raumfahrt experten
und expertinnen macht dem vergangenen
herbst die angabe dass china das labor
schon seit märz 2016 nicht mehr steuern
kann
die folge rang eins bewegt sich seitdem
unkontrolliert auf die erde zu der zeit
kreis die station nach chinesischen
berechnungen wohl in einer mittleren
höhe von etwa 3 111 kilometern im mai
waren es noch rund 350 kilometer
regelmäßig gibt es dazu status updates
aus china jetzt gibt es aktuelle
berechnungen wonach teile der
chinesischen raumstation schon bald auf
die erde stürzen werden
dies wird wohl ende 2017 der fall sein
spätestens aber im april 2018 einen
ähnlichen zeitraum hat übrigens auch die
amerikanische organisation aero space
berechnet demnach wird shandong 1
irgendwann zwischen ende dezember 2017
ende februar 2018 abstürzen also alles
wird schon bald passieren
dann soll shandong 1 in die dichter
werdende atmosphäre eintreten die teile
die nicht komplett verbrennen
also alles was nicht verglühte beim
eintritt die werden dann auf die erde
treffen und dazu hat jetzt der
renommierte astrophysiker jonathan
mcdowell von der harvard university im
britischen guardian geäußert er schließt
nicht aus dass wrackteile mit einem
gewicht von bis zu 100 kilogramm auf die
erde stürzen können das ist nicht lustig
denn im gegensatz zu einem asteroiden
ist der einschlag auf die erde
unausweichlich doch das risiko dass
menschen getroffen werden könnten das
ist nach angaben verschiedener raumfahrt
experten und expertinnen eher klein
das wurde gerade in toulouse verkündet
wo sich in diesem monat mehr als 100
astronauten astronauten zum 30
weltkongress der astronauten getroffen
hatten doch schäden am boden können
genauso wenig wie auswirkungen auf den
flugverkehr eben nicht zu 100 prozent
ausgeschlossen werden noch ist es also
kaum vorhersehbar was genau passieren
wird und wo welche trümmerteile landen
könnten das alles wird sich wohl erst
kurz vorher abschätzen lassen wenn
überhaupt china hat jetzt angekündigt
kurz vor dem absturz eine vorhersage für
den absturz ort zu machen wenn ihr nicht
verpassen wollt wo das sein wollt und
auch videos zu allen anderen themen
nicht verpassen sollte man hier ein abo
aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den genau auf die
glocke damit ihr auch von den neuen
videos erfahrt hier geht es weiter mit
weltraumschrott bedroht die erde mit
noch mehr infos zum thema sehr sehr
spannend und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
ein